Oh God everything's gone no what is it
the today couples are giving each other
surprise hair makeovers I say couples
but I mean me and my wife David's gonna
be consulting each of us in secret but
the catch is were gonna be doing
instructions for our partners hair
there's anyone that could break up me
and my wife
it could be oh great no pressure do you
trust your partner completely yeah I
would say that I trust Aereo if she
totally messes up my hair it'll grow
back right meds hair is just easy he
just showers and then he's like he
shakes it anything I've had the same
haircut my entire life I'm excited to
see what Ariel might want to do
differently I want to give Ned soccer
player hair I feel like soccer players
always love to great looks like shave
the side I think that David Beckham is
the best person to model that's hair
alpha she's got a lot of looks so what
years so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna leave the length on top we're
gonna fade the sides of his hair and
we're gonna pop some color in what if I
have black hair when this
haha I know you're really well sweetie I
already am regretting this I have a
love-hate relationship with my hair it
does weird things sometimes and I don't
want to deal with it I love the look of
like wavy hair but my hair does not do
that she has got this long straight
classy hair but I want to pump up no
I'll pop it up give it some dimension
funky something that she feels like she
can do fun plays with she's an interior
designer it's very hard being an
entrepreneur and I want her to have a
haircut that is always just reinforcing
her confidence so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna shape her hair by cutting it
up above the shoulder a little bit I'm
gonna add some texture some movements
and dimension with color what way what
type of color you just have to wait and
see oh we're getting cut already
Tolu in your mind you think of the air
it's like the best hair you're like
David Beckham has good hair David
Beckham okay quite anymore my dog's hair
cuts five three times as expensive as my
haircut it's a zone of safety for me oh
my god what is you're getting a perm
actually Oh Ariel my life is in your
hands I'm excited but also nervous
whoa am I gonna store it hair I don't
know I am trying to read your face David
I got my hair colored by this woman who
had no idea what she was doing and she
like kept messing up and being like oh
I'm so sorry
and I was like what what do you mean
you're sorry that was very sweet he
actually went to the salon and like told
them that I had it a terrible you did it
I wash so ship walks right in there gave
him a piece of my mind told me go
I like the darker hair yeah makes your
eyes pop what was your first reaction
it's got energy a swoop nature of it
very fashion-forward I think you look
beautiful you think he looks kind like a
pop star yeah I think I like Bob I guess
I just have to see myself in the mirror
now different but it still feels like me
to feel even more confident now take
risk because it pays off
[Music]
[Music]